so welcome to openjs world and today
jesse and i are going to be talking to
you about internet of things with
node.js both practical and fun
before we get started a little bit about
ourselves i'm michael dawson
the node.js lead for ibm and red hat
what that means is i get to be
an active community member i'm a
collaborator member of the technical
steering committee
and generally active across the project
it also gets to me in that mean it means
that i get to work with great teams
across red hat and ibm
for example jesse in terms of our
support for node.js on different
platforms
as well as you know all all sorts of
things in terms of making node.js
first-class citizens
in our offerings and thank you michael
i'm
jesse i'm uh work with ibm as michael
mentioned i'm
the business architect of open source on
a platform known as ibm i
uh which you may have not heard about
before but it's definitely a
a platform with a strong in like strong
footprint and it powered banks insurance
companies
all kinds of fortune 100 and fortune 500
companies as well
uh but in my role here at ibm i get to
set the
strategy around open source technologies
for that ibm i platform around things
like
open source languages and iot
so just before we get started a little
bit of an idea of what we're going to go
through so we're going to start with a
brief introduction to iot
and mqtt so what are they why are they
important
we'll look at using mqtt with node.js
because they're a great fit
we'll take a look at some real physical
devices we'll talk about the anatomy of
a simple mqtt
light and temperature sensor sensor that
might fit one of your business use cases
we'll then show you mqtt and devices in
action
in a demo part we'll then touch on
leveraging
mqtt with the cloud and we'll finally
we'll finish up with a few thoughts on
reactive applications and
kafka so to start with what is
the internet of things generally it's
what's used to refer to a network of
physically connected devices
these devices provide data often you
know a constant stream of things like
temperature
pressure and so forth they can also
often be controlled though you can send
a message back to the device and you
could turn a light on or off
uh open a door those kinds of things and
if you want a more
comprehensive description you can go and
check out the the wikipedia listing
for the internet of things now
one of the most commonly used protocols
with iot devices
is mqtt it's uh mq
it stands for mq telemetry transport was
actually invited and invented by
somebody at ibm quite a while ago and
it's really popular because it's really
lightweight you can do a publish and
subscribe
um so it's it's a message based where
you publish the topics and you can
subscribe
subscribe to talk topics but it's very
small
it's got a small footprint it requires
low bandwidth so you can get it into
small devices
and it's fairly easy to use and that's
you know kind of why it's so popular
again you know if you want to go back to
a reference you can look at mqtt.org in
terms of the the formal definition there
the great thing is it's asynchronous
which is a really good fit for node.js
as we know
so let's dive into some of the specific
terminology so the first thing you need
to know is
um the client and the broker so clients
are basically you know devices
applications running on same ibm i or
some other platform
who connects to a topic either to
publish or subscribe messages
uh there's some great clients out there
so faux
and mqtt js so file is one which
provides clients across a number of
different platforms
and languages mqtt js is a
npm module um written by one of the the
members of the
node ecosystem and you know it's a great
choice when we're using them
the broker is the piece that actually
provides
the the the message cues and the
persistence and
sort of the back and often mqtt is
provided as a protocol along with a
bunch of other
protocols so later on jesse is going to
show us amq
and amq supports a number of different
protocols mqtt being one of them
mosquito is
a uh you know a javascript pure
javascript
broker that you can also use for
experiment experimentation as well so
that's the client in the broker topics
are basically you know an id that we
subscribe to when we want to listen for
messages or what we publish on when we
want to send messages
messages themselves are free form so
they can basically be any any text
so it's up to you to figure out what
that formatting is going to look like
and then qos stands for quality of
service and mqtt
provides three different qualities of
service zero one and two which we'll
talk about in the subsequent slides
so let's look at topics topics are
uh you know one or more levels separated
by a topic setter separator
and in in this example you know we have
factory is one level floor is another
level machine is another level
and i can you know ask when i subscribe
i can i can subscribe to a very specific
level
you know so i can subscribe to factory
floor machine one in which case i'll
just get
uh messages for that one topic or i can
subscribe using wildcards which i show a
little bit below
so that i can get like all messages for
topics that are underneath factory floor
1 for example
there are a few restrictions they must
be at least one character each
each level and they are case sensitive
so it's good to be aware of
wild cards which are very useful when
you're subscribing on topics
are the plus which matches a single
level um
so in this case you know factory plus
slash plus slash machine one will match
factory floor one machine one
but not you know something where there's
two intermediate levels like the second
example
the hash sign number sign matches
multiple levels
but it's only allowed at the end so it
basically says i want to get
messages for all topics below this route
that i'm specifying
and those end up being quite quite
useful
at very least if you're trying to figure
out what topics are available and
messages are
are coming into you on quality of
service
uh there's three levels they're very
simple you know zero is at most once
one is at least once and two is exactly
once
and if you think about simple devices at
least often you know at most once is
is all you need if i'm sending a you
know a stream of
temperature readings it really doesn't
matter if i me if i miss
you know a message
because the next one will come along and
you know i'll still have the data but
depending on your application you can
use
some of the other ones which is like at
least once you're guaranteed to have it
delivered although it may be repeated in
that case
and then two is like its own you're only
ever going to get it
of course as you pick the higher levels
there's going to be more overhead and so
you know unless you really need to you
know zero is probably the way to go
the other thing is is that the qs is
determined
by the receiver so even if you actually
ask for a higher
quality of service when you're sending
you may not get that on
on the other end
so now over to jesse to sort of give us
a little bit of why are people
interested in iot
in our context yeah thanks michael and
you know obviously it's easy to see that
iot
continues to play a growing part in
everybody's day-to-day lives right i'm
guessing each person attending today
uses iot in some shape or fashion and
probably with multiple devices
right we have smart watches smart
appliances smart tvs
smart cars all of these things we call
smart but we have iot devices
uh more and more prevalently available
in our life
but from a business perspective if you
are a developer or a manager or an
architect
and you're trying to see you know am i
in an industry that cares about iot the
short answer is most likely yes
because iot technology now is really
transcending across many different
industries
right um so we have ibm i clients for
instance
in the trucking industry who are
managing their fleet to make sure that
things like the temperature of their
meat when it's in shipment is good to
keep the product safe and so on
you know we have clients in the medical
industry and they're investing in smart
smart devices that are easier to
maintain have
lower rates of failure and things like
that as well so iot
is uh very prevalent in many many
industries these days
um okay now just oh yeah there you go we
lost your video there for a second so
you're back sorry i'm back all right
fantastic
um so we do have there
lost me again all right okay now now we
see again button
all right fantastic um so a simple
publisher example that we have here is
written with that mqtt js project that
michael mentioned
that is relatively easy to use
relatively flexible
and it's kind of the tool of choice for
us because of those
reasons right um
oh lost my video again
we're getting a little bit of technical
uh glitches a little bit of technical
glitches
uh the iot technology works much better
than my current
my current webcam technology but
um top to bottom it's a pretty simple
example
in the sense that we just require some
pretty common modules that you see with
fs and path
we require in this mqtt js module
and you know most of the code is
actually setting up
the ssl bit because we chose in our
demos that we set up
to encrypt the communications with tls
and so that requires us to set up the
options with
uh the client certificate and
certificate authority trust stores and
things like that
and so really you can see we're just
setting that up in this mqtt
options object and then we call the
mqtt.js library to connect
to the broker of choice in this
particular case it's an ibm i system we
use for demo
and then once we're connected we can
subscribe to a topic
and in this case we just spit that
output out to
the console just for quick demo debug
purposes
right and the previous one the previous
page just showed you know
actually publishing on the same topic
absolutely and the code is pretty much
the same it's just the only thing that's
different is what are you going to do
once you get connected you register
a callback for a message received versus
um calling the red readily made apis for
doing that simple publish to
that mqtt broker that's right we just
didn't want people
you know anybody being able to publish
to our broker so we added some security
so now we can move on and actually look
at some some devices
the the you know the the the iot devices
you can use range
from all sorts of different things and
sizes if you look at the
the lower right that's an esp-01
that's a very small but it has built-in
wireless
and you know enough memory to be able to
run a small program
and you know the one beside it is a
slightly larger one that already has
like a usb port
it's uh it's one that i commonly use
because you can just plug it in and now
you've got something that's got some
pins that you can use to
turn things on and off take readings
and then all the way up to something
like on the top left where we have
a raspberry pi where you can run you
know a real operating system
and you know all sorts of things in in
between i kind of like the
the the socket one on the on the right
because that's one where actually you
can load in your own javascript code
connect to an it iot network and
turn the light on and off and stuff like
that in addition to some of the ones
that we've built here
uh this is another one i've worked on
more recently it shows that
uh the wemos mini d1 where it's it's a a
weight sensor
and so basically the the sensor that
that reads the the weight
um you know connects up to that little
device which can then connect and
send over mqtt the uh the weight of
whatever you put on top of it
you might also ask well what about some
existing devices so instead of trying to
to build my own
you know build my own there's a bunch of
devices but not all of them use mqtt so
quite common pattern
is to use a
mqtt bridge where you have that bridge
converting from whatever protocol the
devices are using into the mqtt protocol
in my example there's a lot of devices
out there that you can get that run on
433 megahertz
and so like we have a door sensor a
motion sensor
actually a fire alarm that will go off
and again send messages on 433
the most right one is a is a temperature
sensor
and i have a bridge written in
in in node.js actually that can take the
messages that come in through the
433 megahertz and you know we can
convert them to
uh to mqtt and then use those messages
and actually this one isn't written in
node but this one's uh you know
built on esp8266 that can can do that
conversion
so now let's look at what it would take
to say build your own device just so you
can see that it's really not that
complicated what's going on in the
devices if you want to build something
that's purpose fit
um you know in industrial cases you'll
more likely want to
buy a commercial device for support and
so forth but
you know if you want to start
experimenting and sort of proof of
concept
what you might be able to do in your
business this is a good way to go
starting get started
so let's imagine that for example your
business grows plants
maybe things like temperature humidity
and light intensity throughout the day
might be interesting and you know in
this case this is something that i've
set up i'm growing a few plants
in my basement you know mint and
basil some nice spices stuff like that
and i
ended up you know through through that
device which you can see there
it's built on again one of those esps
and it collects
slight temperature um and humidity
and like you know through the mqtt
network i can fairly easily get that
data out
and then you know i put together a
grafana dashboard that consumes that
data and shows me you know the trends of
the humidity temperature
and light you could set up alerts to say
okay wait a sec the lights went off when
they're not supposed to
or if things are getting too hot too
cold and so forth
this is the version of devices that
we're actually going to show you in in
the demo
um a slightly earlier version of those
i'm just trying to raise it up so you
can see it
and it builds in the dsp has a light
which blinks every time it's sending the
message and it collects light and
temperature information
this is the circuit diagram of what it
looks like so we have that wemos
which has a nice usb port you just plug
in it's got a light sensor which is that
gl
device it's basically just a resistor
that changes resistance
um based on uh the amount of light that
there is
it's connected to the analog pin on the
the wemos
uh through a you know a resistor divider
so that you get a different value
depending on how much light
is being presented and then on the right
hand side is a ds
18v20 which is a integrated temperature
sensor
and basically through sort of a one-wire
protocol
you can talk to it ask for the
temperature and it gives that back to
you
and then you know for uh as shown when
i'm showing the device there's also an
led that we can turn on turn off and
it's set up to turn on and off
whenever it's sending you some data
looking at what's actually in the device
itself uh we saw uh topics so when i
introduced the concepts
uh topics were one of the important
topics and you can see there the late
topic the temp topic and the led topics
so those are the topics that the device
will publish on
when there's a light reading a
temperature reading or or
you know basically you want to tell it
to turn the light on or
if the light changes on the right hand
side we see some of the code and again
just like the case that jesse showed us
earlier in terms of the node client
a lot of this is just boilerplate so
that we can get our
connection to the network and our
certificates
again over here still more sort of
boilerplate the nice thing that you'll
notice here is like
i didn't have to write the code to query
that that temperature sensor there's
already a dallas temperature sensor
um sort of library that's out there and
so we can leverage those in in a lot of
the things that we write
these tend to be um
[Music]
you know they tend to work very much
like you would expect an asynchronous
system and if you're familiar with node
um you know through callbacks so in this
case you know part of the code is a
callback that says when i get a message
posted to a particular topic
um this is the code that i want to run
and in this case it says like you know
when i get a message i'm going to tell
i'm going to check whether that's a
message telling me to turn the light on
or turn the write off and associated you
know it then calls the function that
will actually write the pin
to make that change now we start to get
into the
the code itself and you can see that i'm
creating
the pub sub client and i'm passing here
that callback which we saw on the
previous page to say okay this is the
callback when you get a message that i
want you
i want you to run along with the
connection info that says you know
what's my
mqtt port and server string
the code itself here now is mostly
around
getting the certificates all set up and
passing in a unique id the one of the
key things is
every client really should have its own
id otherwise i found that some of the
brokers get confused so in this case we
use
the the mac address
as a unique id because that's going to
be unique for every day every every
device
and you can see here that uh
when we create our client so we you know
create a client
we've created a client and within this
loop we basically at the
the first we check to say are we
connected to the the wi-fi
if so let's start you know if
if not let's actually say let's connect
and here's where we're passing in that
unique id
and once we're connected we subscribe to
the topic in this case the led topic
that we can send
then inside that loop the other thing we
do is every so often so we've got our
transmit interval seconds and delay
we want to take the temperature sensor
the temperature and light readings
and publish them to a particular topic
so we saw those topics uh
earlier the temp topic and the light
topic so this code basically
you know interacts with the library that
i mentioned
converts it to a string because we said
that the messages were just plain
formatted text
and then publishes to the temp topic and
the light topic
and then toggles the lead so that you
get some feedback that is actually
sending the data out
now i showed you c plus plus if you
don't like c plus and you want to do it
in javascript i won't go through the
same
description but you can do that through
esprino and you can write in javascript
the code looks very similar you have a
similar loop
and in fact i did that to push the same
code into
a demo type device like this and if you
want to go check it out you can go check
out my github repo to take a little more
look and more detailed look through the
code there
so now we're at demo time i'll hand it
back over to jesse
um
so jesse is still there
sorry about that yes i am here um we
are going to walk you through a really
quick demo and then we'll show you the
code behind it
uh what we're actually going to do is
we're going to show
consuming data from these light and
temperature sensors that michael just
talked about
and then we're going to actually store
that information in a database to be
used by other database applications
so set up to get this to this point i
have active mq running on my system and
happens to be an ibm i system but that's
not uh necessarily relevant it can be
anywhere because these are all very
portable and we wrote a little bit of
node code that i'll show you in a little
what bit node.js code does it make sure
that the database exists and you can see
in this case it already
has the schema and everything because
we've run this before
and now because those devices are
sleeping
and sending data as temperature changes
or light changes or every 10 seconds
you're going to see this light and
temperature sensor data
coming in on a periodic basis right and
so
when that light temperature sensor comes
in we see the console output here
and that information is also available
in the database and so i'm going to pop
up an sql tool here where i'm doing a
simple
select from this table that i created
this iot records table
for temperature and center data and you
can see there's a couple tabs that
popped up down in the bottom
and you can actually see uh the
historical
time behind the the various sensor
values for temperature
and for light as well so if you're
interested that's that's the temperature
in my
uh my office and i can actually put my
hand
over the uh the sensors here if we want
to see the light go down
a fair amount um but maybe we'll come
back and take a look at that afterwards
if you want to go
go ahead and show the code yep if we
have if we have time to do that we'll
circle back and do that in a little bit
but the code behind it is going to be
very simple and
very familiar to the code we showed you
earlier in the presentation today
um we're going to set up the connection
to the broker in
exactly the same way we showed you the
example
uh client certificate setup and the ssl
setup and michael
i need to stop sharing oh sorry oh no i
did stop sharing
we need you we need the slides back up
right um
there we go sorry the only thing that's
different is um
you know when we're consuming data we
showed you this one before we're
consuming the data we stick it in
console.log
you see it in the terminal but we're
going to take that a step further like i
just showed so if you go on to the next
slide
we actually wrote some code to store it
to the database
and i'm not going to walk you through
all the details here we're using an ibm
i database connector
creating a table if it doesn't exist and
just doing some basic database setup
there
and if we go to the next slide all we
did is we modified our callback for when
we receive a message
to do a simple insert into statement
with sql
and as you can see it's just a few lines
of code to get that level of integration
and so now any database application can
interact with this iot data yeah and
that's really i think one of the reasons
why it's so popular is that
really very small amount of code just a
few steps and now you've got data
flowing from the devices
all the way into your database where you
can you know take some more
sophisticated action and stuff like that
yep exactly so you know we've shown you
actually connecting the devices directly
to um
the to a system which is running a
broker
if you don't want to set up that that
that yourself um
or you want to make it something that's
like can go across uh you know it's not
necessarily stuck within your
organization one good thing to do is
leverage
leverage the cloud so you could sort of
do um
what's shown in this first picture which
is to move some of the pieces
from your you know internal system out
into containers running in the cloud and
that's actually what i did for some of
the applications i've been playing
around with
is i ran an mqtt broker in the cloud
and then a node application and in this
in this case it's an example where
you know either through through a ui on
a computer or on my phone
i can it can talk to that controller
that controller will convert you know
whatever buttons you press to say
turn on lights turn off lights into an
mqtt message
publish it to that broker that's in the
cloud and then device that device which
is a plug
you know plugged into my house you know
and is
is connected to a wi-fi that can get out
to the outside world connects to the
broker
and you you know now i'm controlling
everything without having to be running
a broker on
my own premises but even better
uh there's a number of iot platforms
that you can get from
from organizations and they will provide
you
all those pieces so that basically you
can just say here's the devices i want
to connect up to
my my my iot system
and you know both from the devices and
from the clients
the thing i did want to mention here is
that there's the
you know the one thing that's a little
bit different is they often have
a few more constraints over things like
the topic so for example
in this particular part of the code i
show that
um you know you need to
change the light topics so they're
structured in a way for example this is
for the watson iot cloud
in a way that that fits their their
environment because it's a multi-tenant
environment so in this case
you know i need to say iot2 event lite
and they even sometimes add some extra
features in this case it's formatting
so i can tell it what format the message
is coming in
and so you know i had to change the
format of my my topics
and i had to change the format of my
messages
the nice thing about that though is that
then they let you very easily
start to chart graph and work with that
data because
you know having it being structured as
json for example they can extract it and
you can put it on charts and so forth so
if you're you're getting into this
that's another good way to sort of have
a quick bootstrap
um to getting charts graphs and data and
all that kind of stuff
all right and i'll quickly just mention
a couple other tools that are available
for doing
iot programming one of my favorites is
node red which actually allows
a low code graphical type of designer
that allows you to just define
your application logic as a flow of data
through all these various nodes
and i worked with a client once who
actually set up a very large
manufacturing integration with plc
devices all linked up through
node red and it was uh it works like a
charm and it's very simple to use
very easy to prototype and deploy to
production so that's something
definitely worth looking into
and another trend that we're seeing is
this
whole notion of reactive systems and so
if you go out and you read the reactive
manifesto it comes in
uh you know various key attributes that
are
are defined as a reactive system right
it needs to be responsive
elastic resilient and message driven
right and so we're seeing an uptick in
interest in messaging technologies and
kafka is quickly becoming the mo the
standard mode of operation
the messaging component of choice um
and so as you're defined defining your
plan for iot you need to also maybe take
this into consideration as well because
your iot data
might need to very very well integrate
with some kind of messaging system
there's a product out there called
apache camel which is really great
as i say for tying anything to anything
including tying iot
devices and technologies to messaging
systems as well
so i'll hand it over to michael to wrap
things up yeah i i you know just to add
on the reactive systems i think you know
the structure uh uh that we've seen in
like the mqtt
uh side of things you know jesse and i
you know joked that we
we only use these devices every so often
but they keep working i unplug them i
plug them back
in and so the reactive systems are sort
of looking to leverage some of that same
same approach where the pieces are
detached and decoupled
um and sort of the message broker is is
the piece that lets you glue it all
together but it's it's a very
resilient um you know approach and way
that you can scale and and yeah we see
that um
kafka is is quickly becoming the the
choice there so when you're thinking
about your
your iot systems today it would be good
to think about like how are you going to
bridge that data into maybe a bigger
uh you know kafka backbone that's
serving your enterprise applications as
well i think that's all the time that we
have today we we hope you
you enjoyed this sort of whirlwind
introduction to what iot is
um some example of what some of the you
know the the
what it looks like in terms of of you
know devices that you could build and
experiment with
how you use uh mqtt with node.js and how
it's such a great fit because you know
uh you know iot is all around being
asynchronous and asynchronous events
and node fits really nicely with that um
and then you know we hope that you see
that like it's
really you know there's it's not that
hard to get started to connect those
devices in
get the data into your database as just
jesse showed
and then even you know leverage the uh
you know larger
cloud-based iot systems or you know
plugging into your more
enterprise-oriented applications that
might be using
uh reactive approaches in kafka um so
thanks for watching
and we hope you enjoy the rest of the
conference